[Musique]
depuis la nuit des temps l'être humain a
montré sa capacité à se projeter dans le
futur tout en s'inspirant du passé mais
sans être esclave du présent mesdames et
messieurs si vous me le permettez je
vous racontais une petite histoire je
pense qu'on devait être dans les années
1940 et donc vous avez un monsieur d'un
certain âge qui analphabète et qui est
ailleurs dans le nord de la Côte
d'Ivoire et donc pour lui son rêve c'est
que ses enfants travaillent deviennent
d'ailleurs comme lui ou face un petit
métier avec leurs mains mais ça c'était
sans savoir qu'il avait un enfant qui
allait penser différemment alors cet
enfant là il y a moins de 10 ans et lui
un jour il décide de faire une grève de
la faim
pourquoi parce qu'il va à l'école donc
le vieux le regard du matin mais c'est
quoi cette histoire non tu vas faire
comme tout le monde tu n'es pas le
premier tu as des anges voilà tu as des
tu as des grands frères et tout ça tu
vas aller comme tout le monde tu vas
devenir il dit non lui il veut aller à
l'école donc pendant deux trois jours il
pleure il se couche par terre il fait
tout ça bon je vous cache la partie ou
la donner à manger dans la cuisine mais
voilà il continue et donc finalement il
faut l'intervention d'un nom mais qui
lui dit écoute le petit voilà à l'école
les seuls à l'école donc il accepte donc
le petit comment aussi va à l'école il
commence à travailler très bien il
avance il évolue lui son rêve c'est
d'avoir son entrée en 6e il travaille la
zone entrée en 6e il travaille tellement
bien qu'on lui dit bon écoute on t'a
fait dans une autre ville pour aller
poursuivre ton tes études donc il va
dans l'autre ville il travaille il
travaille son autre rêve c'est d'avoir
son BPC il travaille il arrive au BPC il
finit il a son BPC donc la famille le
regarde bon c'est bon ton histoire
d'école tu as fini maintenant écoute va
travailler tu vas nous gérer un peu
c'est quoi le problème
lui veut pas lui il a un rêve il va
avoir son bac donc le vieux encore et
c'est bon quoi tes histoires décolle là
c'est bon c'est bon tu arrêtes comme ça
mais non lui continue et donc il arrive
jusqu'en 1er en terminale pour passer
son bac c'est difficile finalement il a
son bac qui travaille pendant un an il
gagne 19000 francs CFA par mois donc ça
ça fait 30 €, il travaille il travaille
l'économise pourquoi il a un rêve il va
aller en France à la fin de l'année il
va en France et ce monsieur là a
travaillé bien il est revenu en Côte
d'Ivoire il a travaillé pendant toute sa
vie il a travaillé pour aider sa famille
et pour faire en sorte que ses enfants
vivent une vie meilleure que lui
mesdames et messieurs ce monsieur là
c'est mon père il est dans la salle ce
soir j'aimerais vivre ma vie allez salut
[Applaudissements]
il y a une phrase de Walt Disney donc
celui qui a créé Disney et tout ça que
j'aime beaucoup il dit pour réaliser
quelque chose vraiment d'extraordinaire
il faut commencer par le rêver et
l'histoire que je viens de vous raconter
là tout à l'heure montre la puissance et
la force de la pensée positive et comme
un enfant a réussi à traverser sa vie
guidée par ses rêves mais l'une des
conditions fondamentales c'est est-ce
que c'est tout
est-ce que le rêve à lui seul peut
permettre de transformer une vie
alors vu qu'on parle ici de rêve je vous
parlais un peu moins de mon rêve mon
rêve en moi c'est de changer le monde et
vous savez quoi je suis pas seul je vois
dans la salle plusieurs personnes qui
comme moi sont un peu et ont décidé de
se lancer dans l'entrepreneuriat
d'autres sont dans des ONG certains ont
décidé d'aller travailler pour les
pouvoirs publics mais toutes ces
personnes là au quotidien changent le
monde
il travaille pour montrer une image
différente du continent il travaille
pour faire en sorte que notre monde soit
meilleur demain et j'ai la chance donc
de faire partie d'une de ces générations
de jeunes passionnés ambitieux qui ont
envie de changer les choses qui ont
envie de faire bouger les choses et ça
fait plaisir de les voir et je suis
content d'en voir un certain nombre ici
on parle souvent des héros des héros
mais voilà ce sont des héros de tous les
jours et eux ils changent le monde au
quotidien alors je vais vous faire
voyager un peu avec moi à travers les
années pour essayer de vous parler un
peu de mon parcours donc on retourne en
2002 je viens d'avoir mon baccalauréat
donc je suis tout content moi mon rêve à
moi c'est d'aller aux États-Unis et donc
je viens à mon entretien donc la dame
c'est une Américaine on discute elle me
pose beaucoup de questions écoute
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire c'est quoi
ton objectif etc donc je réponds je
réponds je réponds et à la fin elle me
dit mais monsieur Bakayoko quand vous
finissez vos études qu'est-ce que vous
voulez faire je dis madame je veux
rentrer pour travailler en Côte d'Ivoire
elle me regarde avec le sourire et puis
elle dit inch'Allah et puis elle met le
tampon
j'allais aussi
donc vous imaginez un jeune de 18 ans
tout content parce qu'il arrive au state
bon Magic System a déjà changé donc j'ai
pas besoin de rentrer dedans mais nous
tous on a été Gaou un moment donc on
arrive tout passionné mais je pense que
de un peu de toute cette expérience de
toutes ces années là-bas ce que je
retiens de cette expérience
c'est le rêve américain
les États-Unis ont réussi à nous montrer
qu'il y avait quelque chose de différent
chez eux que c'était possible
d'atteindre ses objectifs de changer sa
vie que tout était possible parce qu'on
avait le rêve américain
et nous en Afrique ici on a la
possibilité de le faire
et donc
pour moi aujourd'hui après ces années
d'expérience après avoir commencé à
travailler après avoir pris le pari
ambitieux un peu fou mais de se lancer
dans l'entrepreneuriat mon travail au
quotidien mais c'est d'impacter les
jeunes
comment pour moi il y a trois choses
fondamentales sur lesquelles on
travaille c'est vraiment comment est-ce
qu'on réussit à divertir à éduquer et à
développer les compétences
comment réussir à divertir imaginez-vous
un instant que ce soit un enfant un
adolescent un adulte qui entraîne danser
avec son enfant en train de jouer vous
arrivez à lui apporter le sourire à lui
apporter le bonheur est-ce que vous êtes
sûr qu'il va pas vous écouter mais c'est
à ce moment là qu'on réussit au travers
du jeu au travers des activités fun à
leur passé des messages à leur faire
comprendre des choses que ce soit la
sensibilisation financière que ce soit
de leur montrer comment on se comporte
etc mais ces personnes là sont prêtres à
vous écouter parce qu'elles sont dans
des prédispositions
et donc si on regarde même de l'autre
côté quand vous regardez les employés
certains vous voyez sur ces photos là
mais imaginez ces jeunes qui viennent de
sortir qui viennent de finir leur bac
qui viennent de finir leurs études et
qui n'ont jamais travaillé bah alors
dans un environnement cool fun climatisé
il y a de la musique il y a de
l'ambiance et tout ça mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils font mais ils apprennent comment
est-ce qu'on se comporte quand on
travaille en entreprise
ils apprennent comment est-ce que c'est
quand on reçoit un client et on doit
interagir avec ce client là ils
apprennent comment est-ce qu'on gère les
conflits tout ça grâce au jeu
je vous parlais d'un aspect important
aujourd'hui de de de ma vie c'est le jeu
vidéo il y a quelques années j'ai fait
un constat c'est que le monde était en
train de changer aujourd'hui si vous
regardez dans les statistiques vous avez
à peu près une personne sur trois qui
jouent aux jeux vidéos
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un jeu vidéo pour
manger vidéo de façon très simple c'est
vous utilisez un appareil que ce soit un
téléphone que ce soit un ordinateur que
ce soit une tablette vous êtes un
personnage dont vous avez un avatar vous
vous êtes transporté soit un personnage
et grâce à une manette ou à vos doigts
vous avez la possibilité
d'orienter ce personnage là vous avez la
possibilité de pouvoir résoudre un
certain nombre d'énigmes et de faire des
choses vous pouvez le faire seul à deux
à 10 à 20 et aujourd'hui ce secteur
d'activité là qui n'ont fait partie des
industries culturelles et créatives et
donc c'est bien entendu la première
industrie culturelle et créative ça
génère plus de revenus aujourd'hui que
le cinéma et la musique combinée et donc
c'est près de 200 milliards de dollars
chaque année qui sont générés par les
jeux vidéo et ça ne fait que continuer à
augmenter donc vous imaginez un peu
c'est un secteur aujourd'hui pour moi
quand je regarde le jeu vidéo c'est vrai
qu'au-delà du concept un peu préétabli
on se dit bon c'est les jeux c'est pour
les enfants mais aujourd'hui vos enfants
jouent
certaines personnes ici jouent
ils ont leur téléphone ils ont des jeux
mais ils disent pas tout le monde
et donc aujourd'hui pour moi quand je
regarde de façon générale je pense que
le jeu vidéo c'est un nouveau moyen de
raconter les histoires et donc
aujourd'hui le continent africain a la
possibilité de raconter son histoire
d'une autre manière
aujourd'hui nous avons un certain nombre
de sonorités un certain nombre de choses
qu'on aimerait pouvoir véhiculer nous
avons des histoires qu'on aimerait
pouvoir raconter à nos enfants et à ceux
d'après et donc aujourd'hui c'est une
véritable opportunité quand on regarde
on parle d'opportunité quand vous
regardez le marché aujourd'hui sur le
continent africain vous avez plus de 400
millions de personnes qui ont des
smartphones donc c'est à dire des
téléphones avec Internet dessus donc ils
peuvent jouer vous avez aujourd'hui plus
de 1,2 milliards de jeunes donc c'est à
dire de personnes qui ont moins de 35
ans aujourd'hui
quand on parle de la classe moyenne la
classe moyenne aujourd'hui sur le
continent africain est en train de se
développer on parle plus de 300 % de
croissance depuis les années 90 bref ça
fait beaucoup de chiffres mais ce qui
est sûr ça peut marcher ça peut ouvrir
des portes ça peut créer de l'emploi ça
peut ça peut offrir des opportunités
pour la jeunesse africaine
vu qu'on a parlé d'avant on a parlé
d'aujourd'hui on va parler de demain
j'aimerais vous demander pendant deux
trois secondes de fermer un peu les yeux
pensez à Disney
pensez à Mickey pensez à Cendrillon
pensez à toutes ces images là que vous
avez dans votre cerveau depuis tout
petit mais c'est des gens qui ont pensé
à ça qui se sont dit on va créer un
monde merveilleux on va créer du rêve on
va donner la possibilité à chacun de se
prendre pour un roi pour une princesse
pour un héros pour tout ce que vous
voulez et ça c'est un monsieur qui
s'appelle Walt Disney qui à l'époque a
pensé ça et aujourd'hui on réalise même
pas tellement ça fait partie de notre
quotidien mais moi demain c'est ce que
j'aimerais faire j'aimerais créer ce
monde là en Afrique ici raconter nos
histoires permettre à mes trois filles
de comprendre d'où elles viennent leur
permettre de pouvoir rêver de se dire
que ok demain je serai quelqu'un d'autre
je ne suis pas esclave de mon présent et
ça c'est important
et je pense que quand on parle ici on
parlait tout à l'heure de super-héros
mon super héros préféré à moi il
s'appelle Batman il veut changer le
monde mais il n'a pas forcément besoin
que les gens sachent qu'il est et il a
une phrase que j'aime beaucoup qui dit
ce n'est pas qui vous êtes mais ce que
vous faites qui vous définit dans cette
salle ici vous avez des personnes des
directeurs de société vous avez des
personnes qui sont encore jeunes qui
sont employées qui sont ce que vous
voulez mais aujourd'hui ce qui va vous
définir aujourd'hui demain après-demain
c'est ce que vous faites
quelle est la décision que vous prenez
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire comment vous allez changer votre
quotidien comment est-ce que vous allez
changer votre vie c'est le ceux qui sont
à côté celles de votre entreprise
et je pense que ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important tout le monde
rêve un jour de devenir héros de partir
de zéro et de venir héros et ça part de
quoi ça part de vous de cette décision
que vous allez prendre de cette envie de
cette ambition de ce travail que vous
êtes prêt à faire de ce chemin sur
lequel vous êtes prêt à vous embarquer
pour arriver à la finalité
pour moi honnêtement tout est possible
non pas parce que je suis un
entrepreneur et parce que je suis drivé
par cette idée que c'est possible qu'on
va tous réussir etc mais on parle depuis
tout à l'heure de quoi du rêve le rêve
il est au centre de tout ça
il est au centre de tout ça mais en plus
de ça vous avez besoin de beaucoup
d'autres choses vous avez besoin de
combativité vous avez besoin de passer
du temps vous avez besoin de préparation
certaines personnes disent que la chance
n'existe pas que la chance c'est une
combinaison entre la préparation et les
opportunités et donc c'est à vous de
vous préparer de passer le temps de
travailler dur pour arriver là où vous
voulez c'est à vous de prendre la
décision arrêtez de vous dire que
quelqu'un va venir vous récupérer pour
vous envoyer là où vous voulez aller ça
n'existe pas ça à vous de faire le
travail qu'il faut pour y arriver et
c'est possible vous avez de nombreux
exemples vous avez de nombreuses
personnes qui dans cette salle ici ont
réussi leur carrière ont évolué dans
leur vie et tout ça parce qu'ils ont
travaillé ils ont eu la volonté ils ont
eu la passion ils ont mis le temps qu'il
fallait ils ont été résilients et ils
ont eu un soupçon d'audace et je pense
que ça c'est important nous autonome
entrepreneur on jette là-bas et puis on
court maintenant c'est pas où ça va
tomber on sait pas comment on va faire
pour y arriver mais on avance et c'est
ça qu'il faut c'est cet état d'esprit
que vous devez avoir tous les jours vous
devez vous dire comment est-ce que je
fais en sorte que demain soit meilleur
qu'aujourd'hui
alors j'aimerais terminer ici par une
image que j'aime beaucoup c'est un film
qui s'appelle 300 c'est un film de
l'époque un peu qui parle des spartiates
et un peu de cette combativité là de
comment est-ce que on peut avec peu de
personnes on peut de moyens et une idée
un petit rêve un petit truc qui a dans
la tête montrer que c'est possible et
qui va entraîner toute une génération et
les générations et des générations à se
battre pour pouvoir arriver à cet
objectif à cette idée là et je pense que
c'est extrêmement important et la
différence va se passer à quel niveau à
notre détermination à notre volonté
d'aller de l'avant à la décision qu'on
prend mais le pouvoir avancer et faire
bouger les lignes pour notre famille
pour notre communauté pour notre pays
pour notre continent j'aimerais vous
demander mesdames et messieurs de
réfléchir pendant quelques secondes
projetez-vous dans 50 70 ans 80 ans
quand vous êtes à la fin de vos vies
et qu'autour de votre lit vous avez
l'ensemble des idées des projets et de
tout ce que vous n'avez pas pu réaliser
en train de vous dire pourquoi est-ce
que tu nous as pas permis de voir le
jour pourquoi est-ce que tu nous as
gardé dans le placard pourquoi tu nous
as gardé dans l'esprit pourquoi à chaque
fois tu disais ah ouais ça ça peut être
bien non mais ce sera pas possible parce
que j'ai pas d'argent
ah ce sera pas possible parce que j'ai
pas les contacts ah ce sera pas possible
parce que c'est pas le bon moment ou
parce que quelqu'un d'autre a commencé
imaginez-vous un peu tout ça donc
Mesdames et Messieurs c'est le moment
aujourd'hui de vous demander qu'est-ce
que je fais et moi je vous exhorte à
donner vie à vos rêves je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]